bonjour vers à washington a annoncé on
l'a entendu hier jusqu'à 8500 militaires
placées en état d' alerte prêts à
renforcer les troupes de l'otan selon
cela aura-t-il une influence sur le
cours des négociations entre moscou et
washington les rats
bonjour ou a gagné pô par la voix de son
porte parole dmitri peskov le kremlin a
dénoncé la mise en alerte de milliers de
soldats américains
pour lui il s'agit là d'une nouvelle
exacerbation des tensions par washington
ce qui suscite l'inquiétude de moscou je
vous propose d'écouter
cela n'affecte pas le cours des
négociations les négociations en fait
ont été achevés dans le cadre de leur
phase actuelle et avant qu'il y ait une
compréhension de comment et quand nous
allons les poursuivre il faut obtenir ce
fameux texte
nous espérons que nous l'aurons cette
semaine mais ce qui se passe au niveau
informationnelle et factuel c'est
l'escaladé des tensions entretenues par
les états unis nous avons déjà beaucoup
parler lumière rien n'a changé
nous suivons ses démarches avec beaucoup
d'inquiétude
plusieurs pays occidentaux dont les
états unis ont tendance et renforcer
leur aide militaire à l'ukraine
affirmant en plusieurs reprises que la
russie aurait pour projet d'un bailleur
son voisin en dépit des démentis répétés
de moscou qui réclame de son côté 1
renforce un renoncement de tout
élargissement de l'otan à l'est et un
retour à l'architecturé c'est que
sécuritaire construite en europe après
la fin de la guerre froide les
etats-unis doivent remettre cette
semaine une réponse écrite aux exigences
de moscou pour garantir sa sécurité en
plus de l'entretien prévu des dans les
prochains jours entre emmanuel macron y
vladimir poutine une réunion aura lieu
également aujourd'hui à paris entre
conseiller diplomatique français
allemand russe et ukrainien tout en
plaidant la voie du dialogue avec moscou
à travers différents canaux emmanuel
macron affirmé que les robin et leurs
alliés étaient unis en cas d'une
agression russe la riposte sera là et le
coût sera très élevé pourtant le ne
montre pas le même niveau d'inquiétude
que les états unis par exemple
concernant la situation en ukraine ainsi
le 24 janvier le département d'état
américain a ordonné l'évacuation des
familles de ses diplomates en poste à
kiev qu'elle fait à la situation en
ukraine d'imprévisible merci beaucoup
verra pour toutes ces précisions on
verra goffman en direct de moscou ce
matin